it
Ukrainian border guards shared multiple
videos of battles in and around solidar
a move to demonstrate the fighting is
ongoing Global News cannot independently
verify when these images were recorded
or the exact locations
Russia's defense Ministry spokesperson
announced Friday its regular forces took
the town saying full control allows
Russia to cut off Ukrainian supplies and
soldiers going to back moot but on
Wednesday the private Russian mercenary
group Wagner said its soldiers had
captured Solitaire highlighting
potential divisions within Russian ranks
Ukraine says all of the claims are
untrue that solidair has not Fallen
while addressing Lithuanian lawmakers
Vladimir zielinski said the aggressor
must be defeated on Ukrainian land so
that we don't have to fight on the land
of other European peoples
use how battles have been described in
solidarity
just like in nearby back moot which has
seen some of the most intense and deadly
fighting
there are still hundreds of residents in
solidar most have spent their days
hidden away in the few buildings left
standing if Russia's claim is true it
would be the first victory for the
Kremlin since July
Ukraine aided by Western weapons
launched Swift counter offenses and
drove out invading forces from nearly
all of harkiv oblast and her son that
city was liberated in November but that
hasn't stopped Russian missile strikes
much of what's happening in the East is
shared by officials or those linked to
Ukrainian volunteer groups to social
media some of which show jaw-dropping
battles in this nearly year-long War
Crystal gemancing Global News London